hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we were back on monster on a roll again
and today we're gonna be doing the
witcher 3 collaboration quest now I did
see something in a stair that Tut that
said talked to the Third Fleet feline
and now it's giving me a tutorial to go
investigate the the anomaly at the
research base I'm not actually sure if
this has anything to do with this quest
but it was never here to begin with so
we're gonna give it a shot okay I
definitely think this is the witcher 1
queue portal entrance what did I say
uncanny timing Yolo key what a handler
looking real thick right now that means
we do get to play as him that's awesome
[ __ ] yes do you want the help of course
I want the help I get to please him
that'd be so that's so sick oh ok ok ok
interesting so all of these look like
standard monster on our weapons except
this which happens to be the silver
sword alright and obviously I'm gonna
use the silver sword well we got we got
the igni sign potions a lot of potions
some jerky capture net the basic stuff
except this is the only thing I queso
that's the fire one-eyed I completely
forget and his white sharpness [ __ ]
meeting members god damn okay they kind
of got the mission update thing from The
Witcher as well like it I like I don't
know I haven't played witcher like i
said not in a long time so i don't know
if that's actually what that's from like
how they do the quest updates but it's
looking real nice and i'm very i'm
actually enjoying this this is very nice
it's like I'm playing a Witcher quest a
monster honor
holy [ __ ] station to choke them to death
it seems oh [ __ ]
prince was lucky goddamn this dip he
couldn't even move you know feels bad oh
my god oh my okay I thought he was dead
okay I was research Commission oh my god
even at the dialogue from The Witcher it
was like that type of dialogue setup
damn I knew it would take care of this
quick we really thought I was gonna cook
this man alive in between the tree roots
oh wait was that poop get caught up in
the roots oh [ __ ] oh that makes it even
worse I think that makes you that might
make a lot of sense I think that was
Pookie caught up in the roots there god
dammit why does this chick sound like
she has her noses plugged up with a [ __ ]
ton of sinuses with puncture wounds yeah
birds beaks lots of him looks like a
whole flock attacted oh I think we found
it it's a lot of [ __ ] birds black
feathers and the markings the same as on
the previous corpse Fox seems to be
attacking as one these guys are on a to
kill Street
oh [ __ ] I'm here boy the other way these
guys are on a to kill streak though
they're close to a care package if they
keep going one thing that really scares
me though about this quest is really the
fact that I don't want to fail it and
it's really just because I've done so
much already going through it like it's
such a long process going going across
the ancient forests trying to find the
tracks and whatnot and I hope it really
doesn't restart me but like throughout
this entire quest I have to do all this
research again and it just starts to be
like before the flight cuz I'll be fine
with that but I don't want to do all
this [ __ ] again cuz that that'd be way
too time consuming the jaggis are
running that's not a good sign
ah [ __ ] I have at me men have at me men
come on sir
by magic
I really hope we can fight the lesson
but I feel like with this flight it's
gonna give us and then like I know that
like Anjanette is gonna come out and
like [ __ ] us or something I'm not so I'm
not excited for that at all because if
this lesson can control the Jag hrus
holy [ __ ]
you're big better start dodging Darrell
first start using that garden goddamn
he's ass
oh oh it's on now [ __ ]
alright that does some damage not too
much not too much not too bad
oh okay you gotta watch out for that
gotta stop the down smash alright
oh okay yeah that's that one that one
would definitely hurt okay he's got that
move - no problem [ __ ] you
all right so yeah we can use ignite and
then kind of go in for a couple hits
back and forth ah [ __ ] okay see ya when
he goes after the igni we can just do
the the Superman dive and we can go
right into uh
we could just do Superman dive and then
just wait for the thing to just hate us
from the ground
it's got like a couple seconds of a
cool-down so that's not too bad now the
only problem with this is that I'm
actually not really a big sword and
shield fan I don't really use that
weapon as much I would most likely
prefer dual blades uh but the only
reason I'm liking this sword and shield
is just cuz the fact that it's you know
it's Geralt silver sword and it's kind
of nice instead of using like a casual
monster owner dill blade that just
doesn't feel right
they give them that do it's good some KO
damage I don't know how I don't know
what is like ko stuff is just cuz
obviously it's not like your standard
monster or you got but maybe that could
help we'll see I'm just gonna keep into
maybe I'll knock them maybe I'll do some
decent AoE damage what the want to
forget I went out there's the jerky up
with that alright a might I I could quit
you forgot you hate to see this why do
you hate to see these moves
well I was about to do that big up smash
all right so every time I burn him he
seems to keep throwing out more Jagger's
or it's just the fact that I'm like I'm
getting rid of them's and they're like
constantly spawning so I don't know if I
should keep them here by it we're just
gonna we're gonna get rid of them just
in case they end up stacking
while I broke its park it's working
all right well he definitely got hurt
mad hard with that one he does not like
that at all oh and now we're on top of
them come here boy
let me see that face bop
cutting yo [ __ ] up boy how you like it
yeah all we got to do the triple strike
you don't know how much this hurts Bob
sit the [ __ ] down boy
come on
I would dude I was so close oh I know
I'm gonna be dead no [ __ ] I got a little
cocky with that one honestly I probably
would have and I [ __ ] up a little bit
it's uneven like it's not even just
because I was playing bad although I was
of course I was trying to get my sharpen
off and I couldn't do it I was so close
I just couldn't find an opening cuz the
jaggis the amount of jet the Jagger's
that came and then the legend was
ambushing me every chance I got
puppets fly until me one is literally at
the end here he's gonna come into my
side try to go for the move throw that
throw the blast hitting with that hit
him with that heat
Jaggers ain't liking it come on
got him we got lessions skull trial
that's it oh that's that's casual
Witcher you know grabbing the skull of
the enemy or whatever that's some casual
what's your [ __ ]
so he's rarely in one place for too long
damn straight AB rhombic Runestone damn
it's your hunters don't wield any magic
of their own but in hard world magic
exists in some objects as a matter of
course so you tell me we got the igni
sign now never appears again hell yeah
hunters use it to summon flames got a
new gesture got new titles added you
didn't solve all the mysteries try
solving them all in one go interesting I
guess there's more stuff I missed
throughout the game that's a very
interesting thing then sweet I should go
back and do that I'm looking for a lone
sword and show that the Witcher treat so
we get the Witcher silver sword the lush
and skull the cursed bone some stuff
like that cara cara blight or it's got
some decent white sharpness in it a
whole lot of red though so it's gonna
it's gonna cost some of that repair but
I think after you run it a few times you
look at the red the tier 8 version which
is honestly pretty nice I don't know - I
don't use too many dragon type sword and
shields but just comparing damage I'm
not sure maybe the Nagas ghonte sets
better
but 294 - 150 where this is you know 255
3 so I think this is more about dragon
elements so if you do want to have more
of an elemental build they could
definitely use that but in terms of raw
attack I feel like the nerd gurgaon say
set if you're just if you want to rock a
dragon type weapon I think that's your
choice oh this honestly didn't seem like
too bad of a weapon I think that can fit
in the game somewhere so yeah the only
thing else that I found out I don't
think we can get Geralt armor but I did
find the research help creature capture
which is you have to check you have to
capture a creature from another world
and I have to check the monster field
guide so let me go pull that up real
quick ok so here it is it's in the
endemic life we have to capture a Necker
which is doesn't seem to be prying out
other monsters or praying
monsters in the forest perhaps of
foragers and said ventures out after
dark takes their food so I'm assuming to
capture this you'd have to be at night
and then somehow catch up by surprise so
I'm assuming it's very similar to a lot
of the other things you have to capture
with the endemic life so probably whip
out the ghillie mantle and go try to
find it as for where it is I've no clue
big eyes gonna be the end of you today I
hope you guys did enjoy like the video
if you did I might actually go back and
try to do all the side quests and
endings and see if I can actually get a
different ending maybe I'll try that
I'll see if I can give it a shot so
maybe look out in the near future for
that video maybe tonight or maybe
tomorrow morning I'll try to get that
out if I can find it we'll see how that
goes yeah let me know if you guys
thoughts on the witch requests I'm
loving it I'm definitely gonna try to
get the straight sword I think it's
really nice I am not really a big fan of
sword and shields but I might as well
get the silver sword just cuz it looks
cool even know your thoughts be a
subscriber if you're new I cover the
solo guides of most of the monsters in
Monster Hunter world I'm gonna be doing
all the solo guides for every monster an
ice bomb and that releases in October as
well as doing some guides in little
gameplay of the New Avengers your videos
will be on screen guys if you want to
check that out with that guy survive
aggressor day thank vark to the video
enjoy the event quest and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]